speaking of the FBI and the WikiLeaks
emails and John Podesta and Hillary
Clinton in the Clinton Foundation and
all of the stuff Rudy Giuliani former
New York City Mayor and Trump supporter
Rudy Giuliani short-circuited when he
just could not be coherent and actually
make any sense around who is he talking
to what did he know and did the FBI
leaked information to either the Trump
campaign or surrogates like Rudy
Giuliani the FBI is clearly playing
politics here I know some people are
saying David they cleared Hillary
Clinton yeah they cleared her after the
initial announcement during early voting
which absolutely had an impact on voters
now that early voting is done and 30 to
40 percent of the ballots have already
been cast
now James Comey says oh there's not
going to be any charges Rudy Giuliani is
in the middle of this thing in a very
strange way saying Friday that he knew
that the FBI planned to review more
emails connected to Hillary Clinton
let's look first at this video from Fox
News where she Lyon in which case that's
Martha Stewart we get indicted they
weren't allowed to get the medical
records yeah of course well you do that
to an honest FBI agent I mean just an
honest guy doing his job swore to put he
gets angry yeah so this has been boiling
up in the FDIC's genera I did nothing to
get it out I had not no role in it
did I hear about it you're done right I
heard about it and I can't even repeat
the language that I heard so Giuliani in
the past has bragged about ties to the
FBI he said there very clearly he
absolutely heard about it and then when
he went on CNN Wolf Blitzer to cook to
to give Wolf Blitzer a pat on the back
he did a good job you're saying well
hold on a second you have said in the
past that you're in touch with current
FBI agents although now you're saying
you're only in touch with former FBI
agents the implications of this are huge
which is that if current FBI agents are
leaking information about investigations
or announcements they are going to be
making too Rudy Giuliani that is the FBI
clearly involved in politics in the
United States something they should not
be doing here is Rudy Giuliani talking
to Wolf Blitzer and he really gets very
confused here too the Inspector General
of the US Department of
this morning Rudy Guiliani one of Donald
Trump's closest and most vocal campaign
advisors appeared on national television
and confirmed that he had obtained
leaked information about the FBI's
review of Clinton related emails several
days before FBI director James Comey
sent his letter to Congress last Friday
about this matter in fact mr. Giuliani
went even further and bragged about the
information he obtained stating quote
did I hear about it you're darn right I
heard about it so they're saying that
you confirmed this morning you got this
leaked information before the FBI wrote
to Congress about the new review he
wanted that's not correct I've had no
conversations with anyone inside the FBI
I have I have heard for the last four
months a tremendous amount of
information about the consternation
within the FBI the fact that FBI agents
were very unhappy with the way they were
being treated by the Justice Department
that's all true but none of it came from
any current if I haven't talked to a
current FBI agent as I told you in the
last gosh at least eight or ten months
but did you know mister did you know mr.
mayor that the that Comey was about to
make this about right to Congress we did
some checking you were on the lars
Larson radio show the other day and you
said day you are getting that kind of
information from active FBI agents so
you use that term I just want to make
sure make sure we're getting that right
we listen to the audio and you were
talking about current FBI agents at
least in that radio interview with lars
Larson well the information I've been
getting is from former FBI agents
so you missed my head waters Lars I if I
did if I did say that that was wrong I
have not I have not spoken to a on duty
FBI agent about anything on duty I guess
for the last ten months I don't this is
the best right patting first its former
then it's well they weren't on duty at
the time on duty is very different than
former something very weird here and
Rudy Giuliani did not know how to handle
this and Rudy Giuliani has been out of
office now for about 15 years so you
have to wonder if he's kind of
horrifying the time when he was in power
but if you're actually in that sort of
position where you're privy to these
government secrets you'd you'd handle
yourself a lot more diplomatically and
be a lot more cautious about what you
say and he has become very very fast and
loose as far as what he is saying and
who he's saying it to and Lars Larsen
one thing another thing here third thing
to to Fox and Friends none of it makes
any sense at this point it's too late
it's too late for it to make any
difference but it is very unusual what
it was that a tree Giuliani said about
this over time numerous times eluding
with different levels of directness to
knowing ahead of time what we were going
to hear from the FBI what do you make of
it let me know on Twitter at D Pakman